que empecemos analizando el discurso
respecto a la violencia en las Fronteras
del Norte global no que va enfocado en
culpar a las llamadas mafias de tráfico
de personas Pero como si obligaran estas
mafias a las personas a migrar y a usar
rutas peligrosas es esta una manera de
la Unión Europea o de Estados Unidos de
limpiarse las manos es decir estas
mafias digamos no existirían si las
personas pudieran usar vías migratorias
legales
Muchísimas gracias
a todas y todos los que los que nos
siguen Sí en en ese sentido es es
necesario más que recalcar que sobre las
50.000 vidas perdidas durante todo el
mundo Durante los viajes migratorios que
el proyecto migrantes desaparecidos de
la hoym comenzó a documentar desde el
año 2014 no debemos perder de vista y
hacer el llamado a las al respeto del
derecho internacional y también como lo
dice el pacto mundial para la migración
segura ordenada y regular para prevenir
fallecimientos y desapariciones durante
las travesías migratorias ese en ese
sentido qué hacemos hincapié en las
obligaciones en virtud del derecho
internacional incluido el derecho a la
vida
estas deben respetarse en todo momento Y
hacemos siempre hemos desde la desde el
proyecto migrantes desaparecidos así
como desde la organización internacional
para las migraciones siempre hemos
estado a que a que se persiga a los a
los responsables de estas Así es en ese
sentido que necesitamos trabajar juntos
para prevenir y reducir muertes
priorizando las operaciones de búsqueda
y rescate así como mejorando y ampliando
las vías de migración seguras ordenadas
y regulares para asegurar para asegurar
que la gobernanza de la migración pueda
priorizar esas áreas de protección y de
seguridad de las personas en movimiento
creo que
es por otro lado porque no tenemos hay
mucho tiempo para abordar además temas
la cuestión es que las políticas
migratorias en el norte global al final
son una forma de fortificar la riqueza
del Norte construida A base del expolio
del sur no un cambio en la política
migratoria qué aspectos debe tener en
cuenta
Bueno creo que como como el proyecto
migrantes desaparecidos y la
organización internacional para las
migraciones lo han reiterado en
innumerables ocasiones sin duda debemos
enfocar nuestros esfuerzos a que las
vías de migración regulares también
irregulares sean ordenadas dignas y
seguras
enfatizando como los literarios
anteriormente en la protección de las
personas migrantes específicamente las
personas migrantes en tránsito que
circulan estas rutas sin dudas sino
brindamos más caminos tanto de vías de
migración regular y de protección en las
vías de migración irregulares vamos a
tener y a seguir presenciando estos
números tan altos de personas migrantes
fallecidas y desaparecidas durante el
tránsito migratorio y Edwin no tenemos
mucho tiempo pero por ejemplo en Europa
las fronteras están vigiladas con alta
tecnología no radares sensores cámaras
térmicas vallas En qué medida la
industria militar y de la seguridad
influye en las decisiones respecto a las
políticas migratorias porque esta
industria
interesa aumentar la constantemente la
inversión y que estas políticas se
dirijan a la vigilancia más que la libre
circulación
claro esto esto sin duda es esto un tema
verdad el todo el tema de la
securitización de las migraciones o de
un enfoque punitivo o de un enfoque
policial hacia el abordaje de las
migraciones sin duda que es un aliciente
puede provocar fallecimientos y
desapariciones durante el tránsito
migratorio cuando se habla de temas
migratorios en general no solo de
personas migrantes fallecidas y
desaparecidas sin duda tanto los los
gobiernos y los diferentes entes
encargados de administrar las
migraciones en el mundo deben tener
presente que esté abortarse desde un
enfoque humanista verdad priorizando
siempre a las personas migrantes y sus
familias como centro de todos los
esfuerzos que se hagan y comprendiendo
también que la migración en muchos
sentidos entraña una oportunidad de
desarrollo para todas las naciones donde
llegan las personas migrantes que
atraviesan estas peligrosas rutas